well it looks like we could be going
back to masks if you can believe it
according to a new report commissioned
by the Department of Health and Human
Services that says quote the lifting of
mass mandates and indifferent attitude
towards masking and social distancing
typically in many public and private
places further isolates people with long
covid an HHS spokesperson stressed to
Fox News digital that the recommendation
for a new mask mandate came from the
study and not from the Department itself
but they declined to answer if they
support it and it's also important to
note that the department paid for and
publicized the study on their website so
Joe this notion further isolating people
with long covid that sounds like a
suggestion that because those people may
feel like they have to wear a mask
everybody does is that what they're
getting at I hope not because what we've
seen and what we've learned about Mass
over the last two and a half almost
three years now is that people don't
wear them correctly for starters right
how many times you see a guy walking
down the street alone and the mask is
below his nose for example or they wear
cloth masks which are not effective
n35s those are the ones that you have to
wear in order to keep covet out and then
the real problem becomes that at least
in my household you can do all those
things but then around your house you're
not wearing a mask right and all it
takes is just one in my case kids come
home they may have it they're
asymptomatic and then before you know it
I think my wife has had it like four
times now right right so you could do
all these measures to try to contain
this virus but in the end mass or
anything else it's it's just not going
to work it's going to find you whether
you like it or not the question is how
do you treat it and how do you live yeah
n95 Max okay we're having a conversation
about remasking but do you remember when
the president said this in September the
pandemic's OverWatch
is the pandemic over the pandemic is
over we still have a problem with covet
we're still doing a lot of work on it uh
it's but the pandemic is over if you
notice no one's wearing masks everybody
seems to be in pretty good shape
and then I was also reading about this
study out of Texas Texas researchers are
recommending that kids wear a mask to
prevent the flu wow I mean okay where
does it end is the question and also
what is this about is this risk aversion
is this fear is this a control tactic
what do you think it's abusive to our
children in many ways when you consider
their emotional development you know one
of my daughter's first words was mask
and that's so sad that she grew up in
this pandemic environment and that's
what you saw and it inhibits their
emotional learning we know that they
need to see facial expression so it's
very sad that it's being considered for
flu also I love how the administration
says oh no we're not considering a mask
mandate you know they're protesting to
foxnews.com well why would we believe
you because you never overturned the
first mass mandate that was a judge in
Florida named Catherine meitzel and
while everyone on my Airline was
celebrating the mass mandate being
lifted you guys were the ones calling it
disappointing and considering whether to
challenge it in court so we just don't
believe you anymore Natalie what do you
think about this well I think the panda
stomach is over and the vaccines are out
there The Masks are out there if you
want to use them go ahead and use them
but I think the government needs to at
this point admit that that covid crisis
is now behind us we need to focus on
what's at hand and I think that to your
point children's immune systems have
been ruined a lot of people's immune
systems have been ruined by doing that
and now the question needs to turn to
how did this crisis even happen we need
to hold people accountable and the
journalists need to become Watchdogs not
lap dogs about how this coveted virus
got out yeah and there was there was a
big uproar at Dr Anthony fauci's last
press briefing yesterday because a
reporter was asking that question how
did this you know what about the lab
League Theory Dr fauci and green
Jean-Pierre stepped in and said we're
not asking that question right now also
at that press conference cat Dr fauci
made an interesting comment raise some
eyebrows watch this
I know sometimes when you walk in and
you have a mask and nobody has a mask
you kind of feel guilty you shouldn't
feel guilty you look terrific
handshakes are out still according to
him masks are still in though
if you want to wear a mask and you're
one of those people that's wearing a
mask I don't think you feel guilty I
think you feel like however you want to
feel about it that's up to you your
feelings are not my responsibility your
feelings about what you wear whether
it's a mask or a sweater or anything
else that's on you that's not on me and
when you were saying okay they're saying
masks I think long covet because maybe
if you have to think about what are they
really saying it's kind of confusing and
when you're reaching that point where
nobody even really knows what you're
talking about anymore I think it's time
to reassess whether you should just
leave people that's so true I had to
read it a couple times the same I think
this is what they're going to say it's
not even sure to be smarter and no but
no I thought the same one interpret that
and Natalie I thought you made a great
Point uh personal choice that's what it
should always have been about hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights